Anastasia estaba en su cuarto de baño
cuando un proyectil Ruso alcanzó su
edificio de apartamentos en vinipro
desnuda y atrapada bajo los escombros
gritó pidiendo ayuda Antes de que los
rescatistas la localizaran y la llevaran
a un lugar seguro otros quedaron
atrapados entre los restos del edificio
utilizaron las linternas de sus
teléfonos móviles para pedir ayuda
cientos de residentes se unieron a los
servicios de rescate para encontrar a
los atrapados bajo los escombros el
resto vio con horror como su casa se
derrumbaba estaba dormido mientras
dormía empecé a gritar no entendía Por
qué me desperté oí una explosión luego
salí miré por la ventana y sólo había
una enorme nube de humo pensé que el
suelo de la casa se había derrumbado me
preparé salí y la gente gritaba niños
mujeres gente ensangrentada caminaba de
un lado a otro la policía estaba por
todas partes salí pero el de la casa
había desaparecido
[Música]
esto es claramente terrorismo y
Simplemente no es humano la victoria
debe ganarse en el campo de batalla no
entre la población civil
la oleada de ataques también golpeó las
regiones de kiev en el noreste de
harquif y el sur de saporilla y es uno
de sus mayores ataques desde el inicio
de 2023 el presidente dijo que Ucrania
había derribado 21 de los 33 misiles
lanzados por Rusia y pidió más armas a
occidente